So hello, everybody.
I'm really excited to be
here and excited to see
so many people here.
As a big tech policy
nerd, sometimes it's
difficult to find other people
who are really into this.
And so I'm really excited
to meet all of you all
and hear more of what
you're interested in.
So, as mentioned, my
name is Tim Hwang.
I'm part of the public
policy team here at Google.
And in addition to kind of
sort of introducing what we do
and how we can help
you, this session's
going to be sort of a
whirlwind tour of sorts.
We want to basically take you
through some of the issues
that we're thinking
about at Google
and what are the
issues in this 12 to 24
month period that
we think are going
to have the biggest impact
on developers going forward.
So specifically, we're
going to highlight issues
where it's going to have a
big impact on app development
and also on privacy
and security.
And most importantly,
I talk to a lot
of devs who say, well, you
know, this is really exciting.
But how do I get involved?
And so that's the
second part of the talk.
We'll be kind of talking about
open opportunities, where
you can make a difference
on some of these issues.
So I think the
plan is that we're
going to keep it
pretty conversational.
So it'll be about
20, 30 minutes.
We'll kind of go to Q&A. And
I'm fully cognizant of the fact
that this is actually
the happy hour period.
So I think we're going to
keep it relatively short,
and we may just all
host drinks afterwards,
which I'm getting an OK
from that guy up there.
So I think it's a good thing.
So let me go into first a
little bit of introduction
about myself.
So I'm a developer by training,
but I've always kind of
been interested in the
intersection between technology
and the internet and
culture and society.
So I'm the founder of a
conference called ROFLCon,
which I started a few years
back, which the whole idea was
to bring together people
who were momentarily famous
on the internet to talk
about the past, present,
and future of internet culture.
So past guests included Success
Kid, like the actual kid;
the guy who designed Comic
Sans, who apologized;
and the dude from 4chan,
who did not apologize.
And around 2010, I
got really interested
in the idea of automating
law and lawyers.
I had a lot of friends who
were going to law school
at the time, and they were
getting out and telling me
about their job.
And I was like, man, it be
so easy to write software
to try to automate that stuff.
And so I had this dream
about doing this law firm
called Robot, Robot,
& Hwang, which
would be a law firm that
was partially run by robots.
I ended up being
diverged in that process
and started getting really
interested in the ways in which
law shapes technology,
how the rules get
made that shape the kind of
day-to-day of what developers
do, and what people experience
in their technology.
So that kind of sent me
down this other path.
So I ended up doing research at
this place called the Berkman
Center for Internet Society,
interning at this place called
the Electronic Frontier
Foundation, that many of you
may be familiar with, if
you're here in this room,
and working for
Creative Commons, which
is this experiment
around copyright.
Nowadays I lead public policy
at Google on two major emerging
topics.
So the first one is
machine intelligence.
So that's very much
tied to the products
that we've been
working on around AI.
So TensorFlow, which you
may be familiar with,
is kind of our product around
open sourcing machine learning
tools.
As well as the bigger
questions around AI--
what do we think that AI will
do to the future of work,
or how do we guarantee that
AIs will be safe in the future
as we put more and more
things in their hands?
Secondly, I also work on VR.
That has a product
component as well.
So I work on things
related to Cardboard,
but I also think about
the bigger issue, which
is what does it mean that
society is going to experience
more and more media
through the venue of what
is virtual reality?
And so these are a set of
emerging fronts of activity.
And so we're going
to focus today
on things that are going to
have more immediate impact.
But to the extent that
you want to nerd out
about these issues, that you're
excited about these issues,
definitely catch me
at the happy hour.
I'm always happy to
talk about this stuff.
So let's just jump into it.
What is tech policy anyways?
Like I had this
conversation with my mom
the other day, where she
was like, oh, honey, you're
working at Google now.
You actually have a real job.
And then she was like, so
what do you do exactly?
And I'm like, oh, I
work at public policy.
And she was like, what does
that actually even mean?
And we meet actually a lot of
developers who are like, OK,
public policy, like I
have like the vaguest
sense of what that means.
So just to set a little
bit of background,
I would talk about what
we do and then how we
fit into this overall picture.
And it's useful
because it also gives
some context to talking about
how we can help all of you.
So when you say
public policy, it
can sound really
abstract, right?
Sort of like a bunch of guys
sitting in a room with wigs
writing a bill.
And it's for sure that these
guys haven't heard of left-pad.
They haven't heard of GitHub,
mostly because it's 1776.
But generally, that's one
image of what people have
when they think
about public policy.
Another one is they
might kind of conjure up
visions of the "West Wing"
or "House of Cards," right?
And I have to assure you that
my life is definitely not that.
Like I was joking to Wilson the
other day that a lot of my work
is just kind of shuffling
emails around, which
is not as sexy as all that.
So in any case, I
think most people
think about public policy as
something kind of existing,
particularly if you're a
dev, something really kind
of outside of the
world of technology.
And that actually turns
out to be a big assumption.
As someone who formerly
worked at a startup,
I think the usual idea
is that you push code,
and then stuff just kind of
happens in a vacuum, right?
Either the system
is on or off, right?
That's one bit.
And the other one is are more
users adopting the technology
that you built?
And those are the
only two factors
that you're really
worried about.
And you don't really
think about the fact
that what you're
building is going
to get influenced by much larger
forces that are out there.
So technology really doesn't
really think about policy
all that much.
But the scary thing
in our world is
that certainly people in policy
are thinking about technology
all the time.
So some of you might be
familiar with SOPA PIPA which
happened a few years back--
so the Stop Online Piracy
Act or the Protect IP Act,
which in a particular great kind
of DCism, Protect IP, the
"PROTECT" is also an acronym.
So it's kind of this
fractal acronym.
We deal with a lot of
that in our line of work.
And that was so
important because it
would have fundamentally
shaped how content is allowed
to move around the web and
have a big impact on speech--
the kinds of content that
can make it out there.
Or you might
remember the battles
around net neutrality that
happened a few years back.
And that's a particularly
important issue
because it actually
influences how people
can access content and
the kind of services
they have access to.
So what I'm trying
to say is actually
I think these public
policy discussions have
an impact on pretty much
every level of technology.
If you're a developer,
it's the question
of what you can
build and launch.
If you're a startup, it's a
question of what kind of users
you can access and
how you access them.
And as a user, as a
consumer of technology,
as someone who uses
phones and is really
excited about technology,
it's the question
of what you can and can't
do on those platforms.
So that's the work
of public policy.
There are rules, laws,
regulations popping up
all the time and ideas for those
things popping up all the time.
And there's good
ideas, bad ideas,
and pretty much
everything in between.
And so our team
basically plays the role
of monitoring those
developments and figuring out
the bigger implications for
the ecosystem, of which Google
is a part.
Because, in many cases,
these decisions not only
impact the company, but
technology as a whole
or the internet
network as a whole.
And then once we've done that,
we actually spend a lot of time
telling people about it.
So that sometimes
involves lawmakers
who get in touch, saying,
so how does AI work?
And we go through the process
of explaining what that is.
And that's not only
just with our products
but also new trends
as well-- what's
out there, what's happening, and
should I be concerned about it
or excited about it?
It also involves speaking to
particular groups as well.
So one of the things
that I lead up
is specifically the
outreach to developers.
And we think that actually ends
up being really, really key
because they're, A, a critical
part of the ecosystem.
Most of the exciting things
are happening in engineering,
in startups, even outside
of the big companies.
Secondly, they're
super influential when
they do speak on these issues
because these are people who
are directly with
the technology,
understanding the problems that
you face on a day-to-day basis
and really have a sense of
what to be concerned about.
And then finally,
there are actually
people that we want feedback
on some of the issues.
In many cases,
Google is actually
trying to figure out what its
position should be itself.
And so we've actually started
to do much more in terms
of trying to reach out to people
and say, what's your feedback?
What do you think?
And what do you
think our positions
should be on the issues?
So it's a particularly
interesting constituency,
though, because
developers are this kind
of great influential
voice, but simultaneously,
again, if you've done a startup
or you're a part of a company,
you actually have little
time to pay attention
to all this stuff.
You're just busy trying to
make sure that things stay up
and operational.
And so one of the overall sort
of strategies in this space
that we're thinking about is how
do we lower the costs to people
participating?
How do we lower the cost
to people finding out
what's going on,
because you can't always
be paying attention to the
latest bill in Congress.
And often, it's in dense
legalese that doesn't actually
make sense and get
connected to what you're
doing on a day-to-day basis.
So what's that mean?
So I've kind of
rambled on at length
about this in a kind
of abstract way.
So there's three things that
we're doing on this front
that I'll shout out, right?
So one of them is
sessions like these.
We're going all
around the world.
We did a session in Colombia.
We have done a
session in London,
and we're doing a
session here at I/O,
where we kind of
meet with developers
and talk about what we're
seeing both internationally
and in people's home country.
So that's the
first thing, right?
If you are traveling
from out of town
or you have particular issues
that you're interested in
and you would want
an expert from Google
to come and talk
about this stuff,
this is something that we
can definitely help and do.
The second one is actually
we're working to share
our resources more widely.
If you're in a country or you
have a question about an issue,
it turns out there's
probably someone
within the company that's
actually looking and watching
at this stuff really closely.
So we're hoping to be an open
resource for developers that
are out there to have
questions answered,
or actually get in touch with
people who are sort of policy
experts on these issues.
And then finally, we're kind
of experimenting or supporting
platforms for people to find
out more about public policy
and technology.
So, as I mentioned at
the very beginning,
as someone who's really excited
about this intersection,
it's almost a kind
of nerdery that
exists in the broader
world of nerdery,
so it's sometimes
really difficult
to find people to hang out
and talk about these issues.
And so one of things we've
been experimenting is with this
thing called /Policy.
It's basically a Slack
instance-- really casual.
A bunch of developers from
all around the world who
are interested in this stuff,
talking about this stuff.
And we're kind of using
it as a way, potentially,
to get more information out in a
really casual, lightweight sort
of way.
So let's jump to it.
So I've talked a little
bit about what we do,
how we're doing it, and
how we can help you all.
So let's jump into
the actual issues.
What is coming down the pipe for
the next like 12 to 24 months?
And the world is really big.
So I could talk to
you about the coming
battles around net
neutrality in Latin America.
I could talk to you
about age-rating and app
politics in Korea.
But there's two
that are top of mind
for us right now that
we think are going
to have the biggest impact.
And specifically,
they're ones where
we think developers can make
a really big difference.
So I think that's one of the
reasons we're presenting them
today.
So the first one I'll
talk a little about
is the Internet of
Things, and what
we're seeing in the evolving
world around security
and privacy.
The second one is around
fragmentation on Android
and how fragmentation
on the platform
is actually starting
to intersect
with laws and regulations.
So we'll go into it.
So the first one is
we've been thinking
a lot about the
Internet of Things,
and particularly
where things are
going to end up as this
technology becomes more
mature and evolved over time.
And it's a particularly
important space
because we think that
developers have a chance
to set norms for how people
think about these technologies
in a big way.
So context setting first, right?
Let's face it.
Internet of Things-- it's
a total buzzword, right?
But really, all it
refers to is the idea
that everything big
and small is starting
to incorporate computers,
that everything
is becoming a computational
object in some kind.
And so we actually
don't think the future
is going to be some
kind of weird universe
that is "Minority
Report" style and has
screens flying everywhere.
This is an image that we
commissioned internally
to envision what the
Internet of Things
actually looks like in practice.
And one of the immediate
things you'll notice
is actually there's no screens.
That we think that
actually in practice,
devices will sort of be
seamlessly integrated
into everyday life,
in patterns and shapes
that we know and
are familiar with.
So that buzzword,
Internet of Things,
actually doesn't mean
a whole lot by itself.
But what it refers
to is this ubiquity
of computation-- ubiquity of
devices all over the place.
And so it raises all sorts
of really interesting kind
of new concerns.
How should devices be
secured against people
with malicious intent, right?
So I was traveling recently.
I saw a number of people
were like, oh, it's
a bike lock that you open
with your phone, right?
It feels like if the security
there isn't quite right,
that could be a real issue.
How should devices be made
to protect user privacy?
Insofar as you have devices
that are collecting information,
how do we give users the power
to control the information
that they are giving?
And then finally, how should
devices a signal that things
are going right or going wrong?
If the paradigm we
think in the future
is not going to be screens,
then the really big question
is, what are the indicators,
user interfaces, all
those practices that we
need to build in order
to keep people secure
and also people
assured about the
products that they're
building and interacting with?
So with all this, I think
there is actually one approach,
right?
And that approach is
pretty old-fashioned,
which is to say,
let's use the law
to shape the behavior
of people who make
and code these objects--
that is to say,
many of the people in this room.
And indeed, actually,
a lot of policymakers
are thinking about
questions in this space,
and specifically how rules
should look like in this space.
So if you're going to
launch an IoT product,
it has to incorporate
these A, B, C, D things.
But this picture
actually, it just
isn't just about
lawmakers, right?
One of the big things is
it's a situation where
people designing
these technologies
will have a really
big role to play.
And the reason for that--
the intuition for that,
comes from this
guy, Larry Lessig,
that you might be familiar with.
So you might remember him
from Creative Commons.
If you've seen the CC logo
online, it comes from this guy.
More recently, he made a
bid to run for president.
But he's most known in
the technology policy
world for thinking about
the different forces that
can shape behavior.
And what he says is,
OK, there's four forces
you could think about, right?
There's the force of law, like
what's written on the books.
There's the force of norms,
what people agree to do
or what's general
practice in a space.
There's the force
of markets, which
is like the incentives of
people building these products
and putting them
out into the world.
And then finally, there's code.
And in certain situations,
certain of these levers
are going to be more
powerful than others
in shaping the
space, and we think
in the Internet
of Things, code's
going to be
particularly powerful.
And the reason is because
the space is actually
moving so fast and the standards
are being developed so quickly,
that what developers and
conventions and standards
developers land on will have
a really big role in shaping
the norms and laws
that eventually
emerge around the technology.
So the way we think
about it, and the way
that we're starting
to kind of shape up
our positioning internally,
is that if ubiquity
is the challenge of
the Internet of Things,
then trust is sort
of the solution.
If we are interacting
in a space where there's
lots of devices that
look like the devices
we're familiar with, but don't
interact or behave in the ways
that we expect,
then a big thing is
how do we ensure that users
have trust in this space.
And so if you think
about three principles
that should guide
what's happening.
So one is interoperability,
the second one
is security and privacy,
and the final one
is the need for new interfaces.
And there's kind of a product
dimension to all this,
but there's also kind
of a policy dimension
to all of them as well.
So on the product side,
you may have picked up
some of this going
around I/O, right?
Certainly around
interoperability last year
at I/O, we launched
a thing called
Weave, which is an open source
standard around communication
protocols for the
Internet of Things.
The second one is
security and privacy.
We've been porting a lot
of the best practices
that we have in doing stuff
like Gmail into the Internet
of Things space.
And then finally, the
new interfaces stuff,
like a lot of the work that
we're doing on voice interfaces
is exactly tied
into this question.
So this is something
that is still emerging,
and it's actually
something that we're
looking for a lot of
developer feedback on.
No one has all the answers,
particularly because this field
is still emerging.
But people who are
closest to the technology
are going to have the most
practical experience to offer.
And so we're hoping to
develop these practices
into some kind of document
or some kind of convention,
certainly something
that we can take back
and say, well, OK, within
the field, the emerging
field of Internet
of Things, here
are the protocols
and standards that we
see emerging in the community
and throughout the community.
So for what happens
next, I think,
if you're interested
in this stuff,
we're interested in hearing
from you about what you're
encountering, the
troubles you're
encountering, and
the solutions you're
finding to get around them.
Because when we get questions
from policymakers saying, hey,
well, we really want to maybe
think about a regulation
or rule in this
space, we ideally
want to represent sort of the
interests of the community
as a whole, as an
ecosystem, as we push ahead.
So that's the first one.
And you may not work
on Internet of Things.
So that may be
somewhat relevant.
This one I think is a
really big one and I think
will probably concern
a lot of people
in the room, which is
about fragmentation.
Android and fragmentation
and specifically increasingly
how that's starting to intersect
with law and regulators
and policymakers.
I want to talk a little
bit how this actually
impacts developers in a
really key way and then what
developers can do around it.
So for this story,
it's worth going back
to Andy Rubin and the
early days of Android
and the ancient days of the
late 2000s space-- 2008.
At the time, the
idea was, how do you
design an open source
operating system that works
for everybody in the space?
If we're going to launch
an operating system,
how do we generate adoption?
How do we get
something that works
for OEMs, people
designing the phones, app
developers, and then the
users themselves, right?
And the idea was to
kind of create and focus
on open source as a solution.
If you have an operating
system with common protocols
that anyone can pick up and
use, but also is flexible enough
for people to adapt
for their own purposes,
it seems to be the best
way to generate adoption,
because you can sort of
customize for whatever
particular purpose
that you want.
And so to quote the
immortal words of Pokemon,
this was super effective.
At last count, we have
some kind of amazing stats
about the state of the
Android ecosystem, right?
There's more than 400 different
manufacturers, more than 1.4
billion Android
devices worldwide,
and then more than
$14 billion paid out
to developers, app
developers, over time.
And so this is really great.
So it turns out that the
solution of open source
was an amazing way
to gain and generate
adoption in the marketplace.
So this is great.
Problem solved, right?
Well, this is the
problem, right?
As the ecosystem has
gotten bigger and bigger--
and I actually don't
need to tell anyone this,
who develops for Android
in the space, right?
The ecosystem is also kind
of increasingly fragmented
over time.
So this is a visualization from
a company called Open Signal.
And it shows basically all
the device fragmentation
in the space.
And, again, like
Protect IP, it's
almost a fractal level
of fragmentation.
Like you could zoom in, and
there would be fragmentation
in the fragmentation.
That's how fragmented it is.
So in short, openness
was the big strength
and the big success for
the Android platform.
But simultaneously, it
generated a ton of fragmentation
in more and more contexts.
And so that's a little
bit abstract, right?
So let's actually
translate the terms
that if you're designing
or developing for a phone,
you'll understand, right?
So there's one
big cost, which is
the cost of ensuring
performance and compliance
and ensuring performance across
many, many different devices.
So animoca had this image that
got passed around quite a lot
through the web, showing
all the devices they
had on hand to ensure that would
the apps that they're building
actually function properly.
And what thing
we've been starting
to tell more people about--
I think I can say this now.
One thing we've been
telling more people about
is that it actually
impacts Google as well.
So famously, when we were
designing Google Maps,
we too also had a
cabinet of devices
to ensure sufficient kind
of performance compatibility
across lots and lots of devices.
So that's one issue, right?
It kind of raises the
cost of development.
I think if you're
interested in security,
this ends up being
another huge issue, right?
Android, let's face it, has
been faced with security issues,
prominently in the last year.
And it's actually arguably an
additional unfortunate outcome
of fragmentation.
It's hard to push updates.
It's doubly hard to ensure that
all the devices incorporate
the latest patches quickly.
And this creates a number
of risks for the user.
Of course, their
data becomes at risk.
But it also impacts the
ecosystem more deeply,
we think, for developers.
They have to spend more
time to ensure security.
And then failures actually can
harm their reputation not only
the reputation of
the operating system.
So this is the interesting
design challenge
that we're in right
now and something
that we're thinking
really, really
deeply about, which
is, on one hand,
as someone who's a Free
Software Foundation donor
and someone who's really excited
about this stuff, open source
is like the incredibly
powerful design feature that
allowed the platform to
percolate and gain adoption.
Simultaneously, interoperability
becomes a bigger issue
as you have more and
more fragmentation.
So that has this big impact
on sort of developers
on the day-to-day basis.
And we have a couple of levers
for dealing with it, right?
So one way you can read
or think about Nexus
is that it's an attempt to
give Android a platform where
the OS can be uniform.
But obviously, Nexus phones
are not the most popular phone
out there.
So, by far, the
strongest lever we have
is actually a
relationship with people
who manufacture phones, right?
They have an impact.
They are impacted
by fragmentation.
And they have an interest
in the ecosystem as well.
So we make agreements
to basically ensure
anti-fragmentation in the space
to protect interoperability.
Now, the worry is
that without access
to this anti-fragmentation
agreement,
the Android ecosystem might get
even more fragmented over time.
And eventually you could
imagine, particularly devices,
diverging so much that
when you launch an app,
it's actually even
unclear whether or not
the app will run at all across
the ecosystem in any big way.
We also think the impact may be
particularly big on small devs,
because they don't have the
resources to develop and ensure
compliance and performance
across all these devices.
So this is a number
of big issues, right?
And if you've been
reading the news lately,
you might know that
regulators are actually
interested in this
specific kind of agreement,
because they have a huge
impact on the mobile ecosystem
and the app economy.
And at issue is the question of
whether or not these agreements
should be allowed.
And if they are allowed,
what shape they should take.
And these inquiries, I
think, give us a good sense
to understand what
regulators are interested in
and also a chance to talk
about how open source business
models work.
But it turns out, actually,
what's really interesting
that what we're seeing is
that actually it's not just
about Google, but
developers are not,
surprisingly, a big
part of the picture.
So we increasingly hear from
regulators that are like,
can you put us in
touch with developers
who are interested in
talking about this stuff?
Because they're the ones who
stand to gain or lose as much
from this particular issue.
And so it turns out
they're actually
really interested in
hearing from you as well.
So I think the overarching
question of balancing openness
and interoperability is not
an easy one, by any measure.
And it's been actually a problem
with every single open source
project.
If you look at the history
of successful open source,
this actually ends up being
kind of a consistent challenge.
But we basically think it's
important for people's voices
to be heard.
And so if you're interested
in learning more about how
to be in touch and how
to talk to these folks,
I would say just drop a line.
[MUSIC PLAYING]